Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ist es nicht schön, dass wir jetzt beide im Risikogebiet wohnen?
No risk no Fun und äh Joe Biden hat äh keine Ahnung, ihm fehlt die Erfahrung erster Hand.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertdreiundsechzig, wenn ich richtig informiert wurde von meiner Taskforce und ähm ja, jetzt äh versinkt schon wieder alles. Alles in Corona.
Achter Oktober ist heute, ne? Viertausend, Neuinfektionen wurden gemeldet. Geht wieder gut, ne? Berlin haben sie jetzt äh machen sie jetzt äh Sperrstunde?
Ist super, immer wenn ich meine Reiseplanung gerade vorantreibe, passiert wieder irgend so ein Mist. Ich habe mir jetzt schon drauf eingestellt, mich jetzt irgendwie täglich äh testen zu lassen, damit ich irgendwie überhaupt noch irgendwohin darf.
Was kostet so ein Test inzwischen?
Na ja, so wenn du es selber machen willst, kannst du dafür achtzig Euro irgendwie einen auf Amazon klicken und dann.
Ja, aber das war doch irgendwie komisch mit dieser hin und her Schickerei oder so. Hattest du in UKW erzählt.
Ja, gut, aber die Verzögerungen, die da entstehen, sind jetzt auch nicht anders als die Verzögerungen, die du normal auch hast. Und von daher macht das auch keinen großen Unterschied.
Was kostet ein normaler Test? Also mit Service.
Mit Service habe ich jetzt selten irgendwas unter hundert Euro ja so im Bereich von hundertfünfzig Euro gesehen.
Also.
Ja, also war, also ein Walkin habe ich tatsächlich in Düsseldorf auch für äh eher so im Bereich achtzig Euro war das, glaube ich, gemacht. Also du kriegst es quasi günstiger, wenn du mehr oder weniger dort die Probe entnehmen lässt, wo,
Testdienst, also dies,
wo mehr oder weniger das Labor selber äh die Probe entnimmt, weil er halt da nicht noch einen Mittelman dazwischen ist. Und wenn das über einen Arzt läuft, dann wird's halt schnell etwas teurer.
Musstet ins direkte B2C gehen, ja. Eine.
Ist natürlich auch die Frage, inwiefern solche äh Selbstentnahmen äh anerkannt werden, ne, weil dann kannst du natürlich alles Mögliche hinschicken.
Das ist ja eigentlich eher nur zu gedacht, um dir selber oder Leuten, die dir uneingeschränkt glauben, äh entsprechend zu vermitteln, dass alles okay ist, aber na ja Gott, das sind halt so die Werkzeuge, die man hat.
Hm
Na ja, also ich bin sehr gespannt. Es ist aber tatsächlich möchte ich anmerken, es ist genauso gekommen, wie ich es seit Monaten vorhergesagt und beklagt habe, spezifisch hier in Berlin, kann es nicht,
also ich kann es mir nicht verkneifen, festzustellen, dass ein großer Teil,
von mir beobachten, gastronomischen Einrichtungen auf diesen ganzen Corona äh Schutzmaßnahmen sehr äh offensichtlich geschissen hat
und äh das Infektionsgeschehen sich dadurch eben auch äh,
sehr stark äh vergrößert hat, nicht unbedingt spezifisch, dadurch, dass jetzt bestimmte Bars äh zu Corona-Hotspots geworden wären, sondern weil die eben dabei geholfen haben,
diesen Kram zu vergessen. Ja, also äh mir berichten meine Freundinnen in der Gastronomie, dass bei ihnen zum Beispiel Gäste reinkommen mit den äh Corona-Registrierungsformular, äh.
Äh belästigt werden und sagen, ne, dann gehe ich woanders hin, ja? Äh was bedeutet, irgendwo anders wird das nicht gemacht.
Und ähm ja
wir kriegen's jetzt hier volles Fund auf die Kappe und das trifft natürlich wieder alle. Also es ist also vor allem alle gastronomischen Einrichtungen. Auch die, die sich dran gehalten haben, mit anderen Worten, wir haben hier,
Gesundheitsregulatorische Vorgaben gehabt und die Leute, die sich nicht dran gehalten haben, profitieren jetzt im Prinzip davon, ne? Und werden dafür belohnt. Und äh alle kriegen die gleiche äh Strafe. War
abzusehen, so ist das mit den ähm,
Konflikten, äh wenn sich eben Vereinzelte einen Vorteil verschaffen können, indem sie äh an sich an Regeln nicht halten,
und die Konsequenzen davon alle tragen müssen, ne. Haben wir ja mit äh was weiß ich.
Äh Ressource Ressourcen, Ausnutzung, Umweltverschmutzung und sonstigem ebenso. Also haben wir das auch mit der, mit der Corona Verschmutzung. Ähm.
War von auszugehen. Viel Spaß zu Hause, Arschlöcher.
Ich find's mal ganz entspannt, falls wenn die Gesundheitsämter mal in der Lage wären, mal auch
genauere Statistiken da drüber zu veröffentlichen, was denn so ihre Erkenntnisse sind, wo denn nun diese Infektion vermutlich mehrheitlich stattgefunden haben. Darüber habe ich noch relativ wenig gelesen.
Also man kann da viel vermuten.
Wir kommen gleich nochmal ein bisschen zu den Gesundheitsämtern. Da hat sich nämlich, glaube ich, auch wenig getan. Lass uns mal ganz kurz ein paar Sachen Feedback, also wir haben,
enorm viel Feedback bekommen zu der äh Sendung mit ideal. Äh ähm größtenteils Lob, aber auch einige Kritik. Ähm.
Ich würde das aber jetzt hier so ein bisschen überspringen und einfach auf die äh lebhafte Diskussion in den Kommentaren verweisen. Stattdessen würde ich noch ein bisschen ähm,
Feedback zu vorangegangenen Sendungen benennen. Einmal haben wir über und gesprochen.
Und uns Lynxes darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass Harald Welke,
der in der Open in der Open-Source-Szene und in dem Chaos-Computerclub denke ich schon so ein Legenden bis äh,
Hackerstatus hat. Ich glaub war auch öfter mal im CAE zu Gast.
Mhm. Richtig.
Der hat also der entwickelt sehr viel an Osmu kommen,
Also Open Source, Mobile Communications, quasi Open Source äh Mobiltelefoniestext und er hat natürlich auch ein äh programmiert, das wurde durch den finanziert,
und eben CCC Mobilfunknetz,
wurde das auch schon mal ausprobiert, also auf den, in dem Testnetz, das auf den CCC Veranstaltungen läuft, da äh hat dann auch der Präsident funktioniert. Äh mit anderen Worten,
wir haben.
Wir haben äh in und hier, ne, wieder schön, wir haben's Open Source, wir haben's sogar von staatlicher Stelle oder mit staatlichem Geld gefandet, ja. Hier liegen und äh ja, das äh ist auch wieder so ein wunderschönes Beispiel für,
Deutschland.
Ein CBC.
Dann äh schreibt uns Funky äh etwas längerer Kommentar,
Ich bin Hörer der ersten Stunde bei euch und zähle LNP zu meinen Lieblingspodcast. In letzter Zeit bemerke ich aber doch so ein Trend bei euch, den ich nicht wirklich gut finde. Ich als Bayer, aha. Bin es ja gewöhnt, dass alles und jeder aus Berlin per se alles, was mit Bayern zu tun hat,
erstmal Kacke findet. Gut, leider oft berechtigt,
aber eben auch sehr stereotyp. Wir machen es euch und dem Rest des Landes ja auch nicht einfach, weil wir immer die größten Idioten nach Berlin schicken, damit sie uns zu Hause nicht mehr auf den Sack gehen.
Siehste? Und genau das ihr das Wissen nicht tut, das erklärt auch, ne, wie man äh wie's in den Wald hineinruft, äh so schallt es hinaus, ne?
Wir schicken unsere Idioten nur nach Europa.
Naja, ähm wir wir lassen unsere Idiotenflughäfen bauen. Also okay, dann sagt der.
Aber neulich bei der Thematik in Stuttgart haben dann mal die Schwaben ihr Fett abbekommen und manchmal habt ihr schon ein bisschen den Habitus, dass ihr in Berlin ja die Weisheit gepachtet habt und alle anderen haben ja eh keine Ahnung. Das
hat nichts mit Berlin zu tun, das ist bei mir eine Grundhaltung, aber okay. Ähm.
Aber auch mit Berlin.
Dass ich da einfach nur die ironischen Anklinge überhört habe. Gut, wenigstens willkommen, dabei wenigstens kommen dabei wenigstens meistens gute Gags raus.
Vielleicht könnt ihr ja ab und zu mal etwas auf die Bremse treten.
Weniger gute Gags oder was?
Weniger bessere Gags ähm so ähm ich hoffe, dass verständlich ist, dass wir das mit einer gewissen Ironie tun. Ja, wir wissen, dass es ähm.
Also wir müssen da ja auch einen gewissen Minderheits Minderwertigkeitskomplex von Berlin kompensieren, wenn wir.
Ja, ihr habt auch die Kohle da unten. Euch geht's.
Wenn wir Städte anschauen, die äh ne, im bei die funktionierende Infrastruktur.
Ja, saubere Bürgersteige und alles. Internet habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch. Ja.
Rasen, geputzten Hausflur.
Naja, okay, also weiter geht's. Und neulich hat sich vor allem Linus über die Bürgerinitiative in Grünheide zum Tesla Werk lustig gemacht. Zu dem Themenkomplex hat ja Deutschlandfunk einen Hintergrund gemacht. Den habe ich übrigens auch gehört, ist einer meiner Shownotes verlinkt. Dabei geht es aber weniger um
irgendwelche Tierchen, die da geschützt werden sollen, sondern vor allem darum,
hier nur mit vorläufigen Genehmigungen gebaut wird. Dabei fehlen vor allem Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen. Die Angst besteht hier wohl, dass dann Fakten geschaffen werden und die lokale Politik
Blick auf die Arbeitsplätze, dass dann irgendwie durchwinkt. Und das kann ja auch nicht in unserem Interesse sein.
Dass dann jemand mit genug Geld mehr oder weniger machen kann, was er will. Auch wenn es durchaus was Gutes für die Region dabei bei sich hätte. Gut, kann man natürlich nicht alles wissen. Ich hoffe,
ich habe das jetzt nicht zu komisch ausgedrückt, sollte kein großer sein, sondern eine ein Gedankenanstoß. Aber ich hoffe, ihr macht noch lange weiter und freue mich schon auf die nächste Folge LNP. Liebe Grüße, Funky. Ja, also.
Zunächst einmal sollte schon jetzt schon klar geworden sein. Wir hauen auch gerne auf Berlin drauf. Aber kein Problem.
Ja, also, Frank, ich würde sagen, du kannst nach, du kannst auch gerne nach Berlin ziehen, allerdings dann bitte ähm.
Nicht äh zu überhöhten Preisen. Ähm dann äh dann bist du auch hier willkommen,
aber ähm ansonsten würde ich eigentlich sagen, das mit vorläufigen Genehmigungen gebaut wird, ist in vielen Bereichen des Baugewerbes normal. Ich habe mich da umgehört bei befreundeten Architektinnen und Bauleiterinnen.
Das ist also nicht etwas, ähm vollkommen absurdes, dass so etwas geschieht, ja?
Tesla.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist das ist normal und das geschieht dann eben auch auf das eigene Risiko. Der Bauherrin. Ähm worüber wir ja eigentlich eher in diesem Fall von Grünheide gesprochen haben, ist ein generelle ähm,
deutsche Tendenz, dass man sich, dass die Leute sich zum Jagen tragen lassen, ne? Deutschland bremst sich einfach ähm konsequent aus.
Und selbst wenn dann quasi aus dem äh Ausland innovative Unternehmen kommen, dann wird das ausgebremst. Und wenn man sich diesen Deutschland vom Hintergrund anhört, muss man ja schon auch sagen, dass äh diese Leute da,
nicht äh also ja, sie tragen Argumente vor, aber die sind jetzt auch, also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so etwas wie dass sie da schon,
so klug waren ein, eine seltene Käferart anzusiedeln oder konkrete äh Bedrohungen hätten. Aber natürlich muss das auch diskutiert werden.
Aber ähm so insgesamt hat man bei den Leuten schon mehr rausgehört, nicht dass die eine Sorge hatten, um äh dass hier irgendetwas passiert,
was sie gerne verhindern wollen, was im umweltlichen Bereich wäre und was man regeln könnte, sondern dass die wirklich einfach dieses Testa-Werk nicht haben wollen. Ähm,
Zweiten, also deswegen, Deutschland bremst sich bei solchen Dingen immer gezielt und selber aus und das ist katastrophal. Und das ist auch in Berlin so und ich mache übrigens auch keinen Hehl daraus, sage ich jetzt hier ganz ehrlich, Berlin ist scheiße.
Ja? Kannste eigentlich keinem antun, diese Stadt. Das Problem ist, der Rest von Deutschland ist leider noch scheißer.
Und äh das äh aus diesem kleinen Delta ziehen wir unsere Arroganz.
Und außerdem äh glaube ich, dass wir es euch äh Bayern und Schwaben zeigen werden, wenn unser Flughafen erstmal fertig ist, da werdet ihr noch richtig staunen, was wir hier können. Schaffe, schaffe, Flughafen baue.
Der ist übrigens fertig.
Ja, ja, der ist schon lange fertig. Ich habe den.
Der ist jetzt auch offiziell fertig.
Ja ja, ich habe den, ich habe den auch, äh ich habe den ja auch schon vor Jahren mal besichtigt, da war der auch schon fertig. Habe ich hier, glaube ich.
Aber nicht abgenommen, aber jetzt ist er abgenommen.
Haben die Baugenehmigung?
Die arbeiten an der Abrissgenehmigung, weil jetzt brauchen ja auch keiner mehr, fliegt ja keiner mehr.
Okay, also ja äh ich kann das verstehen, nehmt das bitte nicht ähm ernst ähm oder persönlich, wenn wir.
Unserem ähm unserem Unterlegenheits- und Minderwertigkeitsgefühl als Berlinbewohner dadurch Ausdruck verleihen, dass wir über strukturstarke Regionen Deutschlands lästern.
So ist das. Hinter vorgehaltener Hand äh kommt das alles zurück. So, dann.
Eigentlich wollen wir, eigentlich wollen wir nur so sein wie ihr, tief in unserem Herzen.
Also es gibt ja ich äh es ich finde München tatsächlich übrigens eine schöne Stadt. Im Gegensatz zu Stuttgart übrigens.
Jetzt reicht's aber, jetzt reicht's aber, komm.
Also, so die äh dann schreibt uns Marko,
langes Thema immer hier bei uns gewesen, die Corona-Warn-App äh einmal in Google frei, Marko schreibt uns, wir hatten ein vor kurzem einen kleinen Diskurs über die Schnittstelle von Deppe, dazu hier ein Update, dass MicroG Projekt vor einigen Tagen über sein GMS-Core-Modul eine freie Implementierung der äh API integriert
diese steht schon auf Git Up als APK zum Download bereit und wird wohl auch in verfügbar gemacht werden. Er hat das damit auf seinem
Linage US zum Laufen bekommen und damit gibt es also jetzt die äh Corona-Warnapp für.
Auch für notorische Google Skeptiker,
ähm und deswegen hat Marko uns darauf hingewiesen. Das ist doch das Schöne an offenen Standards.
Womit wir bei einem weiteren Thema wären, dass ich äh aus aus verschiedenen Feedback von Hörerinnen äh mal ansprechen wollte. Und zwar
haben sich
mehrere Gastronomen und Gastronomen mal bei mir gemeldet, die sich so ein bisschen Gedanken machen über den die Zellwirtschaft, die da existiert und ich habe ja ähm.
Hier in der Sendung, mehrfach und auch in den Pressemitteilungen des CCC zu dem Thema mich sehr klar für das äh System stark gemacht. Jetzt gibt es,
folgende Problempunkte, die mir dazu gemeldet werden. Den ersten hatte ich gerade Eingang schon so ein bisschen gesagt, dass eben tatsächlich,
mehrere gastronomische Betriebe, das offenbar einfach nicht machen oder so nachlässig machen, dass sie
Dafür eben keinen Streit mit ihren Kundinnen anfangen. Was wiederum dazu führt, dass bei denen die es ernsthaft betreiben, tatsächlich Unmut von den Kundinnen kommt. Ja? Ähm zweitens, dass die,
ganzen Zettel, wenn sie handschriftlich sind, ist natürlich diese Thema mit den falschen Angaben,
und Unleserlichkeit gibt. Und drittens hat sich hier bei mir gemeldet die Betreiberin einer etwas größeren gastronomischen Einrichtung, die auch einen Coronavorfall hatte und die dann sagte so, tja, das sind eben
fünfhundert solche pro Tag.
Und äh von diesen Zetteln hast du das Problem, die sind eben in keiner Form digital erfasst, du hast dann da die Sache mit der Unleserlichkeit, du hast die Sache mit dem A ist das jetzt eine eins oder eine Sieben, ja und,
dann dieser Alarmierungsprozess kann einfach bei dieser Menge kaum noch,
zeitnah funktionieren. Das muss man leider einfach mal so festhalten
ja? Wenn dann diese die also fünfhundert Zettel, ne, das ist ein Stapel Kopierpapi
der muss zum Amt gebracht werden, weil diese Alarmierung macht das Amt dann und dann kann man sich überlegen, wenn hier Leute anrufen oder Briefe schreiben, da geht auch wieder so viel Zeit verloren. Also habe ich mal darüber nachgedacht.
Ob und wie man denn einfach und Daten sparsam diesen Prozess,
bilden könnte. Und nach einigen Überlegungen bin ich zu dem Konzeptvorschlag gekommen.
Den wir hier schon öfter mal erwähnt hatten oder angedacht hatten, aber ich will den mal formulieren. Und zwar ist das die Ergänzung der Corona-Warn-App, um den Datentyp einer Zusammenkunft,
Zusammenkunft ist wichtig. Es gibt zwei Anwendungsfälle, die ich dafür hätte. Mir geht's hier spezifisch
um die Situation, mehrere Menschen befinden sich zusammen in einem Raum für eine bestimmten, für einen ausgedehnten Zeitraum, was nach meiner, sagen wir mal, ein schlecht gelüfteter Raum oder sowas, was nach meiner
Wahrnehmung irgendwie auch so diese ein Meter fünfzig Situation irgendwann auflösen würde, ne? Enger Meetingraum, zehn Leute drin, da bin ich vielleicht
niemals ein Meter fünfzig nah, trotzdem ist er in der Lage, uns alle zu verseuchen. Anderes Beispiel, ähm ne, was weiß ich, lädt's ein paar Leute zum Kochen ein.
Und äh schließt die meiste Zeit in der Küche. Also der Datentyp, der Zusammenkunft, der wird nach meiner Vorstellung ähnlich gehandelt wie eine,
ähm also von der
vom Backend ähnlich gehandelt wie eine Person, hat aber, weil er ja eine Zusammenkunft ist, nicht mehr diese Anforderungen geheim gehalten zu werden. Also er müsste kein Rolling Identify haben. Könnte er, brauch aber nicht unbedingt. Ich stelle mir das so vor
Ähm.
Und zwar für Restaurants oder jetzt irgendwelche persönlichen Treffen oder so was, gleichermaßen. Du gehst in deine App und sagst, ich möchte jetzt eine Zusammenkunft machen.
Deine App sagt, alles klar. Ähm diese Zusammenkunft ist jetzt registriert und.
Display dir einen QR-Code. Die Leute, mit denen du die Zusammenkunft hast, scannen den QR-Code und speichern sich diesen
Identifiere. Jetzt hast du den auf deinem Telefon und die anderen Leute auch auf ihrem, der den quasi ausgelöst hat, hat die Möglichkeit, die Alarmierung,
auszulösen,
wohlgemerkt, die Datenhaltung ist wieder nur in diesem Benutzerinnenkreis. Das heißt, bis das ausgelöst wird, weiß ähm eine Apple Google oder von sonstem bereitgestellte Schnittstelle nicht,
Das ist diese Zusammenkunft überhaupt gab. Und wenn du jetzt die Alarmierung auslöst, weiß die Schnittstelle auch wieder nicht, wo diese Zusammenkunft war.
Und das Handy speichert sich einfach Uhrzeit und den Code und die Veröffentlichung wäre dann eben,
wiederum Code und Uhrzeit, sodass du ähm dann sogar so abgestufte äh,
Meldung wieder hättest und sagst halt, ja klar, es muss auf den Tag bezogen werden oder dass du als alarmierende Person zum Beispiel auch sagen kannst, alles klar, hier Restaurant,
Mittwoch, Donnerstag hat 'ne infizierte Person gearbeitet, ich alarmiere jetzt für diesen Zeitraum also du könntest.
Die die zentralen Änderungen während der automatische Teil fällt weg, weil du ja auf eine gewisse Weise den Check-In auch,
sicher und nachvollziehbar machen muss, das ist denke ich notwendig, weil ja auch nach den Strafen für diese korrekte Coronaregistrierung, wenn da Ordnungsamt vorbei käme, ähm.
Du einen Nachweis haben musst, dass du das getan hast, der wäre im Prinzip deine Gäste.
Eben darauf aufmerksam zu machen, dass sie diesen Check-In machen müssen, wenn sie's nicht tun.
Ihn halt einen Zettel zu geben. Ne, Zettel voll weg, kann man immer machen. Ähm aber in diesem Fall wäre halt eine super schnelle Alarmierung fähig,
möglich und du könntest nach meiner Abschätzung auf diese Rolling Identifiers verzichten?
Könntest aber natürlich auch ein in dem QR-Call letztendlich etwas drin haben, was zu einem äh Rolling-Code führt, solange der Online
irgendwie dann generiert würde. Hielte ich für 'ne relativ einfache Ergänzungsmöglichkeit,
für eine Schnellalarmierung könnte alternativ oder parallel zu Zellwirtschaften verwendet werden.
Sehe ich wenig Anlass, das zu äh das nicht zu bauen. Zumal, wenn man sich überlegt, was wir hier durchaus an an verrückten Digitallösungen gesehen haben, also die Schwachstellen da drin,
darf man ja nicht. Ähm äh.
Außen vor lassen. Den würde in diesem Konzept, was ich jetzt hier äh im Prinzip sehen würde, wegfallen, weil die Datenhaltung wie der,
dezentral ist.
Und ähm du quasi dann eigentlich deine deine Zusammenkünfteliste hättest mit Datum und Orden, hast du irgendwie was weiß ich, dein dein Diary und,
Am Ende wär's quasi die die dezentrale Umsetzung von dem Kontakttagebuch, was der äh Drosten auch empfohlen hat.
Hielte ich für eine sehr eine wieder mal eine so einfache Lösung,
ein komplexeres Problem zu lösen. Ansonsten würde ich noch kurz erwähnen, was ich gesehen habe, was ich auch sehr,
interessant fand, wo man auch mal denkt so, man muss auch nicht jedes Problem Over Engineer, habe ich in Berlin in einer ähm in einem Biergarten gesehen,
Die haben im Prinzip gesagt, jo, du musst, wenn du hier rein willst, musst du dich,
Corona registrieren und die haben das ganz einfach über eine E-Mail gemacht. Die haben einen QR-Code gehabt, der äh letztendlich,
einen Link mündete, wo du eine E-Mail an die geschickt hast.
Und ähm diese E-Mail auf diese E-Mail kam Autoresponder und der wurde am Eingang kontrolliert. Vorteil, ja, von der Datenhaltung,
Nachteil ist, du hast eine zentrale Datenhaltung, aber wenigstens ist die ohne Zell. Du kannst sauber nach vierzehn Tagen oder was auch immer die Löschfrist in deinem Bundesland ist, einfach die die Inbox löschen.
Also das ist eine sehr einfache Löschfunktionalität und du hast eine sehr schöne Alarmierungsfunktionalität, weil wenigstens die erfassten Kontakte jetzt in einer digitalen und eindeutig der Person zugeordneten Form vorliegen,
Im Zweifelsfall gehst du einfach auf den auf den Tag in deiner Inbox, äh markierst äh alle Nachrichten, das Replay all ähm und äh,
Achtest darauf, dass das im BCC ist und bist fertig. Ja, wo ich mal sagen muss so, tja, ganz ehrlich, ähm.
Ich habe schon sehr viel unsicherere Systeme gesehen als dieses.
Auch wenn es natürlich, ja, ist dann bei Google ja äh äh unterliegt der Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder irgendwelchen Erfassungen, ja ja das ist alles richtig, aber es ich habe sehr viel schlechtere Systeme gesehen.
Na ja, so viel dazu.
Ja, ich will das gleich mal weiter äh äh denken, im Prinzip könnte man ja auch diese Funktionalität, dieses Ich habe mich hier kurz äh äh für diesen Ort registriert, genauso natürlich auch in die Corona-Warn-App direkt eintragen,
Ja, wäre ja durchaus vorstellbar, dass man sozusagen dadurch so ein so ich habe jetzt mich für diesen Ort angemeldet
und ihr wisst das jetzt, weil ich euch den Antwortcode hier sozusagen präsentiere. Man könnte quasi dasselbe
haben, dann müsste man noch nicht mal selber was vorhalten oder alternativ wäre ja auch zu überlegen, dass auch diese Corona-Warn-App einem irgendwie so ein,
so ein Kurzstring erzeugt sozusagen einmal sagt so, ja, ich will mich jetzt hier in die Liste eintragen, ich melde mich mal äh kurz anonym an, damit ich äh benachrichtigt werden kann, wenn hier was war
dass ich hier war, trage ich halt einfach nur so ein acht Buchstaben Code, der in dem Moment für mich erzeugt wird, in diese Liste ein, die man einfach eingeben kann.
Also quasi das System nochmal umdrehen mit den Rolling Identifiz, dass du,
aber also dass du die dass du im im Krankenhaus hast schon im im Restaurant die Erfassung machst und das Restaurant kann ich dann über die über die gleiche alte Schnittstelle im Prinzip durch einen äh durch einen Code identifizieren.
Ja, ob's dann technisch wirklich genau dieselbe Schnittstelle sein kann, ähm lasse ich nochmal offen, aber man kann ja
sozusagen hier auch noch einen zweiten Kanal hinzufügen, der explizit dafür äh gedacht ist, weil man muss jetzt auch grade denken, wir sind jetzt gerade dabei, bei so einer weltweiten europäischen äh europäischen und weltweiten Standardisierung, ja, wo dann auch andere Server zum Einsatz kommen, der ihnen jetzt nicht die deutsche Corona-Warn-App,
ist und dazu natürlich kompatibel sein muss, aber man könnte dem ja quasi noch eine zweite äh Infrastruktur, die ähnlich funktioniert, danebenstellen, um eben genau solche Dinge ab
decken zu können.
Wer bei dem von mir gerade vorgeschlagenen äh System mit äh eventuell statischen Code für die Location, beziehungsweise die Zusammenkunft und die Uhrzeit auch notwendig, ne? Das wäre eine andere API.
Genau, also da müssen wir sicherlich technisch auch nochmal im Detail äh mehr drüber nachdenken, aber es ist äh äh sicherlich machbar und vor allem, denke ich mal, wäre es auch schön, wenn man mehr hätte, wenn diese App
einem quasi auch noch ein bisschen Last von den Schultern nimmt, weil grad dieses Eintragen in äh Listen, ne, was du ja vorhin
auch äh kritisiert hast, dass Leute das in Berlin nicht tun und wahrscheinlich auch an vielen anderen Orten auch nicht tun. Ähm,
es gibt ja oft auch gute Gründe, warum man das nicht will, ne.
Ich denke da mal so an Frauen und so weiter, die jetzt nicht unbedingt grade ein Interesse haben äh in in jeder Kneipe äh mal ihre volle Anschrift zu hinterlassen oder gar ihre Telefonnummer. Ja, da sind.
Die Fälle häufen sich ja auch des Missbrauchs dieser Daten. Ist ja nicht irgendein theoretische.
Ne? Genau. Und wenn ich halt einfach mit der Corona-Warn-App äh ich mache die App auf und sage so, ich will mich jetzt hier in diesem Ort einchecken, ja?
Ähm und ich schreibe dann kriege einfach so ein Kürzel,
das trage ich da irgendwie ein und bei einer Überprüfung könnte halt eine ein Gesundheitsamt einfach dieses Kürzel eingeben und dann plimpt es bei mir aufm Telefon, ohne dass man weiß, wer ich bin
Ja, so nach dem Motto hier, sie waren an dem Ort da vielleicht, Corona, bitte melden sie sich. Dann wäre ja auch schon mal was geworden. Also in der Hinsicht würde ich dann auch,
gerne mehr sehen, ne. Was ich bei UKW auch schon länger angesprochen habe, das vielleicht nochmal als letztes hinterher, dass man vielleicht auch darüber nachdenkt, aber das ist dann eher eine Änderung
auf der gesamten Framework-Ebene, also etwas, was auch bei Google und Apple äh Freunde finden müsste, dass man eben diese Risikoparameter, die derzeit da bewertet werden, die ja im Wesentlichen derzeit nur berücksichtigen, wann war eine Infektion und so weiter und wie
ne, wie wie sehr steigt äh das Risiko pro Tag oder senkt sich äh entsprechend ab, also dass diese,
die letzten Endes dazu führt, dass dir gesagt wird, dein Risiko ist hoch oder niedrig.
Dahingehend erweitert wird, dass man vielleicht auch unterscheidet, ob man nun drinnen oder draußen war,
dieses Ding mit, wir haben hier eine Zusammenkunft und so weiter, das funktioniert natürlich äh gut, wenn,
es sich wirklich um eine solche handelt, aber es gibt natürlich auch genug Situationen, wo man,
drinnen mit Leuten zusammenkommt, die man jetzt irgendwie nicht alle kennt und wo man jetzt auch nicht äh fröhliches Code austauschen organisieren kann oder möchte und äh da wäre es halt schon ganz sinnvoll, wenn diese Telefone mal eine Unterscheidung machen würden,
Natürlich so ein bisschen die Apple Perspektive und kann mir halt sehr gut vorstellen, dass es so auf so einem iPhone kein großes Problem ist, intern so eine Funktion zu realisieren, die einfach sagt, so, ich sehe hier keine GPS-Athleten mehr, also bin ich wahrscheinlich drin
das so ohne weiteres auf der Plattform auch durchsetzbar wäre technisch,
nicht so richtig beurteilen, aber ich fände es auf jeden Fall mal so eine Sache, in die man mal diskutieren sollte.
Ja und das könnte also ich denke, diese Unterscheidung in ähm.
Indoor-Outdoor ist einfach sowas von ähm notwendig. Also ich hatte ja hier,
Zuletzt von meinen neuen Begegnungen niedrigen Risikos ähm gesprochen. Ich habe jetzt inzwischen wieder vier, ne, also das geht hier also das Ding.
Das kann ich sagen, die App funktioniert, aber ähm.
Halte es für von allem, was ich über dieses Virus gehört habe, ziemlich relevanten Unterschied, ob diese Begegnungen niedrigen Risikos, zum Beispiel eine Person waren die vier Meter von mir entfernt, zwei Stunden in einem Restaurant gesessen hat,
oder ähm eine Person, äh die vielleicht ähm an der an der frischen Luft vier Meter entfernt von mir gesessen hat. Insofern diese Unterscheidung,
denke ich, ist insbesondere jetzt für den, für den Winter besonders notwendig und das ist das, was ich wirklich an dieser App kritisieren muss.
Wir haben das Ding damals gelauncht mit der Überlegung, okay, es ist relativ klar, dass die Parameter der Detektion,
über die Zeit, den wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen angepasst werden müssen. Und da ist einfach nichts passiert
da ist nichts passiert. Äh die es wurde irgendwann einmal vor Monaten gesagt, Risikokontakt ist, was weiß ich, diese Zeiteinheit, diese Nähe, ja, aber,
Da muss doch inzwischen viel mehr drüber bekannt sein, wie der Hase läuft und das müsste sich auch in dieser App abbilden und das passiert einfach nicht.
Das äh wie gesagt, denke ich, also zumindest dieses, also das könnte man auch durch diese diesen Datentyp, der Zusammenkunft eben auch ein bisschen.
Ähm ja noch verbessern, ja. Tja, scheint da ist irgendwie Stillstand.
Dass äh da bin ich wirklich mal gespannt auf die Evaluation von diesem ganzen Bluetooth Gemesse und so. Also, dass das auf jeden Fall nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss in der Erfassung sein kann, war von vornherein klar. Und da hätte ich mir inzwischen ein bisschen mehr Fortschritt gewünscht.
Ja
Sicherlich, also zumindest, was die europäische Debatte betrifft, ist es äh angezeigt, wenn man sich jetzt mal international anschaut, wie sehr äh die Verbreitung dieses Konzepts überhaupt äh vorangeht. Da ist ja bisweilen sehr ernüchternd, also nicht,
nicht ohne Grund haben ja Apple und Google auch so diese Apples Funktion äh eingebaut in dieses Frame,
dass man jetzt im Prinzip nur durch das Aufsetzen der entsprechenden Server automatisch diese Dienstleistung einer App
die ja letzten Endes nicht sehr viel mehr macht, als ein paar Abfragen auf einer ABI zu machen. Das können natürlich diese Telefone theoretisch auch alleine. Nur wer äh eben gerne
jetzt in seinem Hoheitsgebiet gerne mit so einer App präsent sein will, kann das eben weiterhin tun, so wie es eben jetzt äh Deutschland viele andere Staaten machen
die bisher darauf verzichtet haben, könnten halt auch einfach nur die Open Implementierung von Googles äh Kieser.
Ja, das das hatten wir ja hier ausführlich berichtet. Das Problem ist nur, äh ich sehe trotzdem, also was ich mir mehr gewünscht hätte, wäre, dass dieses das an diesem Konzept mal weiter entwickelt wird.
Nee, klar, ich sage ja nur, das ist das, wo derzeit der Fokus drauf liegt, äh diese Verbreitung äh von dem Ganzen voranzutreiben. Wir wissen ja nicht,
nicht auch an diesen ganzen anderen Erkenntnissen was gemacht wird, nur die Debatte darum hätte ich natürlich auch,
gerne und dazu äh das dann vielleicht mal unsere Rolle, dass irgendwie man einfach mal drüber diskutiert, äh wie es denn nun weitergehen soll und weitergehen kann.
Dass die App halt als solche nützlicher wird auch in anderen Bereichen, um einfach die Benutzung auch noch weiter zu promoten.
Ja. So, wir haben mal wieder ein EuGH-Urteil zum zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ist das eine gute Nachricht eigentlich?
Ähm nee, weiß ich nicht, weiß ich nicht genau.
Man nicht, ne? Ist vielleicht eine gute Nachricht. Vielleicht nicht, nicht ganz so schlechte Nachricht, brauchen wir auch. Ja, genau.
Vielleicht eine gute Nachricht. Brauchen wir mal ein Jingle? Vielleicht eine gute Nachricht.
Vielleicht eine gute, nicht ganz so scheiße.
Kurz noch mal den Hintergrund. Also, zweitausendsechs hatte die EU per Richtlinie beschlossen, dass es äh eine Fortdatenspeicherung geben soll und zwar für Verbindungs- und Standortdaten sämtlicher Telefon und Internetnutzerinnen.
Auf Vorrat, ja? Um diese Daten den Polizeibehörden und Strafverfolgern irgendwie zur Verfügung zu stellen. So, die wurde also zweitausendsechs beschlossen. Ähm,
Es gab dann in Deutschland und in den einzelnen Ländern diese ganzen Klagen, aber wir bleiben ja hier nur auf der EU-Ebene. Diese Richtlinie,
Hat der EuGH zwanzig vierzehn für unverhältnismäßig und grundrechtswidrig erklärt. Ja? Auf auf EU-Ebene.
Dann ähm wurde gegen nationale Gesetze geklagt und da hat der EuGH zwanzig sechzehn geurteilt.
Diese nationalen Gesetze von Großbritannien und Schweden in dem Fall zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
unverhältnismäßig und nichtig sind, ne? Sie hat die Richtlinie.
Äh weggeurteilt und dann die verbleibenden Ururteile zu deren Umsetzung,
die verbleibenden Gesetze, zu deren Umsetzung auch in den einzelnen Ländern nochmal als nichtig erklärt.
Diese Rechtsprechung des EUGH wurde aber einfach von mehreren EU-Staaten nicht akzeptiert. Die haben sich einfach geweigert ihre nationalen Gesetze zu Vorratsdatenspeicherung abzuschaffen.
So und die EU-Kommission,
die eigentlich dann Vertragsverletzungsverfahren anstrengen müsste, hat sich gedacht, ah ey, heute, heute ist echt schon busy Tag und so, ne und vor allem finden wir eigentlich eh gut so, äh mache ich morgen, ja? Das heißt, die haben quasi
seelenruhig gegen die EU
Vorgaben und EuGH-Urteile verstoßen, aber die EU hatte keine hatte keinen keine Motivation. Die Kommission hat keine Motivation, Vertragsverletzungsverfahren einzuleiten. So,
jetzt haben erneut drei nationale Gerichte den EuGH äh zu dem Thema angerufen,
und das war das englische Investory Power Stripunal. Der französische Corsaitar,
und der belgische Verfassungsgerichtshof. So, die haben also jeweils gefragt, wie sieht das aus mit unseren nationalen Gesetzen, sind,
zulässig. Das Ganze wurde angestoßen durch Privacy International und Lackfaderatur Dunette und jetzt.
Ist es so, dass es, ich rede die ganze Zeit von EU-Ebene. Es ist in Deutschland immer noch eine Klage gegen das Gesetz zu Fortseitensprechung. Unter anderem von Pet
der ja äh letzte Woche bei uns war und äh von der Datenschutzorganisation Digitalcourage. So, jetzt
Also das sind die Nationaldinger. Jetzt aber das EuGH-Urteil, die sagen, ähm,
solange die absolute Notwendigkeit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht bewiesen ist. Und keine gezielte Speicherungspflicht in Betracht gezogen wird, geht das schon mal.
Nicht diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und Sie haben,
natürlich, wie das bei so verfassungsurteilen ist, etwa Spielraum gegeben für Ausnahmen. Und da haben sie gesagt, äh eine Ausnahme ist, wenn der betreffende Mitgliedsstaat mit einer ernsthaften Bedrohung der nationalen Sicherheit konfrontiert ist.
Äh die sich als echt und konkret oder vorhersehbar erweist, kann er das machen. A.
B, aber nicht anlasslos. Also in irgendeiner Form, es müsste gezielt sein. Wie das genau zu interpretieren ist, ist zum heutigen Stand, ist jetzt immer noch so ein bisschen unklar.
Aber man muss sich natürlich fragen ähm ob das denn überhaupt geht, ja, wenn also eine konkrete,
vorhersehbare äh ernsthafte Bedrohung,
Sicherheit der nationalen Sicherheit, zweifelhaft, ob das bei den äh deutschen Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetzen der Fall ist. Und zweitens, Anlasslosigkeit ist auch gegeben, mit anderen Worten, relativ klar,
deutsche Fassung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist auf jeden Fall damit nicht vereinbar, insofern kann man eigentlich auch davon ausgehen, dass das Bundesverwaltung Verwaltungsricht.
Ziemlich zeitnah über das deutsche Gesetz sofort entscheiden kann. Weil es eben nicht mit dem europäischen Recht vereinbar ist.
Ich kriege ich kriege leider gerade eine Nachricht rein vom deutschen Innenministerium, das sich äh äh äußert. Ja, ja, wir danken dem EU-Gerat für die für die Klärung und äh sehen auch weiterhin unsere Pläne unverändert vor.
Wir sind anderer Rechtsauffassung als der.
Danke, dass ihr euch da, dass ihr euch das mal angeschaut habt. Wir haben da was gelesen mit Ausnahmen? Nehmen wir. Ausnahmen? Ja.
Es kann ja nicht sein, dass hier das äh das EuGH der der Strafverfolgung.
Ja, es gibt da etwas Spielraum, hast du ja selber gesagt, ne? Also Spielraum nehmen sie sofort.
So, dann gibt es noch eine kleine Veröffentlichung von Patrick Breyer, nämlich eine Studie des Wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Europäischen Parlaments.
Die sich untersucht haben, ob denn die Gesetze zur flächendeckenden Vorratsdatenspeicherung der Telefonmobil und Internetnutzung.
Einen messbaren Einfluss auf die Kriminalitätsrate oder ein Aufklärungsquote hätten. Das ist ja ganz,
also das ist ja, du hast ja immerhin eine schöne Studiensituation, dass du jetzt quasi in verschiedenen europäischen Staaten diese Speichung hast oder nicht. Jetzt geht der europäische,
der wissenschaftliche Dienst des EU Parlamentes hin und sagt OK guckt mal ihr habt das jetzt seid so und so lange zeigt mal Zahlen ja? Machen wir jetzt mal 'ne ordentliche Studie ja wie sich grundsätzlich die Kriminalität entwickelt hat und so und wie sich die Aufklärungsquoten verändert haben. Und.
Die Studie kommt zu dem Ergebnis, dass es nicht möglich ist, einen direkten Zusammenhang zwischen
Datenspeicherung und Kriminalitätsstatistik zu erkennen. Also weder auf Kriminalitätsrate noch auf Aufklärungsquote gibt es einen Zusammenhang. So und das wiederum ist ja hier für die äh für das
EuGH-Urteil eben auch nochmal relevant, dass sie sagen, so äh ihr müsst erstmal die absolute Notwendigkeit beweisen. Und.
Das ist alles, alles nicht gegeben. Und wir können jetzt uns natürlich darauf freuen, in den nächsten Jahren, wie alle diese Studien und alle diesen Urteil, alle diese Urteile weiterhin ignoriert werden. Das muss man ganz einfach mal sagen.
Ja, das sind ja auch nur so wissenschaftliche, spitzfindigkeiten.
Ja Haarspalterei.
Ja, also da fehlt ja jegliche politische Interpretation. Willst du jetzt hier einfach mit Fakten antworten? Wo kommen wir denn da hin.
Wer hat das letztens noch gesagt? Die Wissenschaft ist ja erstmal Wissenschaft lassen. Jetzt brauchen wir Fakten. Wer hat das denn nochmal gesagt? Der war auch so ein Strategere.
Sorry ich nicht.
Warte mal, das habe ich doch irgendwo.
Oh man ey.
Wer war das denn? Irgend so ein also.
Na ja, wenn man jetzt Wissenschaft und Fakten googelt, dann findet man halt, ne, die Tatsache findet man halt den Fakt, dass Wissenschaft, der einzige Weg ist, Fakten festzustellen, aber okay, lassen wir das. Äh Fakten ist ein schönes Stichwort.
Gibt ja auch noch andere Möglichkeiten, dagegen vorzugehen.
Wogegen? Gegen Fakten?
Ja. Wie du jetzt gleich vorstellen wirst.
Ach so, ja. Äh und Turnit Effekts, Turnifts, ne. Ähm.
Wir haben ja hier in der Sendung berichten wir immer wieder über das Problem der ähm der gesellschaftlichen Verzerrungen und Phänomene,
durch soziale Medien, wobei hier der Kernpunkt des Problemes sicherlich jene Algorithmen sind, die einerseits die Zeit, die wir in den sozialen Medien,
verbringen. Optimieren, also erhöhen sollen, um dem Vermarktungswerbe und Einkommensinteresse, der sie betreibenden Unternehmen zu dienen.
Gleichzeitig dadurch zu einer äh Filterbabilisierung und extremen Meditisierung der,
gesellschaftlichen Wahrnehmungen führen, die Menschen aufgrund dieser sozialen,
Medien entwickeln. Ja, also mit anderen Worten, du guckst einfach nicht mehr so oft auf Facebook, wenn's langweilig ist, mit anderen Worten, es ist in ein sehr gutes Interesse von denen, dass du.
Dort Dinge findest, die dich fesseln und in ihren Bann ziehen, zum Beispiel den unerhörten,
Fakt, äh dass irgendwie äh ne, die Eliten dieser Welt äh Kinder foltern um an daraus zu kriegen.
Und dann ähm wie war das nochmal?
Ich krieg's jetzt gerade nicht mehr ganz auf die Kette. Das muss man auswendig lernen, weil das so absurd ist. Das ist ja nicht in sich geschlossen.
Ja, die die haben dann Kinderpornoringe in irgendwelchen Kellern von äh Pizzarestaurants, die gar keinen Keller haben.
Und der Trump rettet die Kinder, ne?
Hm, klar, Traumpräsident überhaupt die Welt, so einfach ist das.
Es noch nicht verstanden hast, also wirklich.
Das äh genau, äh die Rede ist von.
Dieser ja diesen Konglumerat an Verschwörungstheorien, was letzten Endes bedeutet, dass äh Trump ist so eine so eine Art Erlöser und ähm irgendwie wird er, ist das jetzt alles quasi die Rettung?
Und äh Facebook hat vor einiger Zeit schon gesagt, okay, wir werden jetzt die ähm.
Militarisierten sozialen Bewegungen von unserer Plattform werfen, wenn sie Gewalt befürworten, was bei regelmäßig der Fall ist. Und haben jetzt eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, dass sie ab heute
auch äh sämtliche Facebookseiten Gruppen und Instagram löschen, die für non stehen. Auch wenn sie keine gewaltbezogenen Inhalte enthalten. Mit anderen Worten
Das ist jetzt schon wirklich eine krasse ähm Ansage und auch natürlich ein krasser Einschnitt. Und.
Bei Netzpolitik ORG wird äh äh wurde getitelt, was ich sehr interessant fand ähm Facebook verbietet Q-Anon.
Äh was ich insofern bemerkenswert fand, weil das, was die machen, muss man leider sagen, die verbieten das nicht, sondern die zensieren das. Ne? Das ist weiterhin erlaubt und Facebook kann auch gar nichts verbieten. Ähm,
weil die ja kein Gerichts kein kein Gesetz gebender Körper sind. Die können natürlich nur ihre eigenen Regeln machen, wenn sie da bestimmte Gruppen diskriminieren, dann ist das eben Zensur. Und,
Das Spannende finde ich aber, dass also ich finde das nicht gut, dass sie das tun und.
Es zeigt aber, dass ihnen ihre Algorithmen zum Fangen unserer Aufmerksamkeit heiliger sind.
Als ähm sage ich mal.
Alles andere und deswegen sagen sie, okay, dann machen wir lieber, zensieren wir die hier ganz runter. Hauptsache, wir können unsere Algorithmen so schön halten, wie sie sind, ne.
Die andere Interpretation wäre, dass diese Gruppen so mächtig sind, selbst wenn sie durch die Algorithmen äh diskriminiert werden. Das ist
aber zum Beispiel noch der Stand bei Twitter, die haben die Reichweite von rund einhundertfünfzigtausend äh einschlägigen Konten, beschränkt mit anderen Worten, die kannst du, also die werden dir nicht mehr angeboten.
Und rund siebentausend äh gänzlich gelöscht. Ich,
bin mir nicht sicher, ob diese Maßnahmen so äh von Erfolg gekrönt sein werden oder ob das vielleicht auch eine Symbolpolitik ist. Ich bin schon darüber einig, dass der Kampf gegen diese,
Verschwörungsmythen unbedingt geführt werden muss und dass da auch noch irgendwie kein Kraut gewachsen ist und wir alle keine Ahnung haben, wie wir wie wir das Ding hinkriegen. Aber es ist schon.
Eine schwierige Präzedenz, die da geschaffen wird. Muss ich leider sagen.
Ist eine schwierige Präzedenz, grade äh im Hinblick, wie du richtig sagst, dass dass wir eigentlich aber auch
alle nicht so richtig wissen, was wir äh stattdessen tun sollen und ähm ist auch klar, dass damit natürlich die Leute jetzt erstmal nicht aus der Welt sind, dieser Algorithmus, der,
wie du meinst, Facebook heilig ist, naja, der ist ja nicht heilig. Das ist sozusagen das ist.
Ihr Geschäft.
Genau, das das ist die Definition ihres Geschäfts. Das ist das, was die Kraft einer eines Netzwerks, die Kraft,
Einer einer Plattform ausmacht, diese Recommentations, diese Aufmerksamkeit, die du dann verkaufen kannst, die kannst du nicht so ohne Weiteres aus diesem Laden rausnehmen, ohne den ganzen Laden,
auszunehmen. Und daran haben sie natürlich kein Interesse und da werden sich äh mindestens unterbewusst immer gegen wehren, wahrscheinlich auch eher bewusst,
Auf der anderen Seite kann es sein, dass dir jetzt einfach äh wieder öfter Flat Earth Videos vorgeschlagen werden.
Oh Mann, ey.
Habe ich nämlich eine ein ein wunderschönen Analyse äh gesehen,
die irgendwie so ja und so weiter und was sind da überhaupt und das kann man ja alles die Banken und warum glauben denn die Leute dann trotzdem noch irgendwie dran?
So, das war ja auch so ein bisschen so diese Fragezeichen. Und auch das, was wir jetzt über und so äh vorgebetet haben, denkt sich ja so, jeder normale Mensch,
Ja, okay, gut, was jetzt? Hier fehlen ja irgendwie nur noch Aliens und und dieser ganze andere Kram. Was bitte ist das, ne? Und.
Einerseits ist das halt alles nichts Neues. Also ich habe ja auch vor es gab ja auch vor zwanzig, dreißig Jahren gab's ja schon diese Zeitung,
in irgendwelchen Läden zu kaufen. Wie hießen die immer? News of the World oder irgendwie ähm habe gerade äh keine passenden äh
Namen parat, aber so diese Drecksblätter, wo wirklich einfach die ganze Zeit das volle Programm von Alien in
Führung und also Elvis lebt, zum dreißigsten Mal und so und abgeschwächt dafür ähm Form gibt's das ja auch so mit so Frauen und Gesellschaftsmagazinen, wo die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Kinder von irgendwelchen
Grafen und und und Königinnen erfunden werden, ne? Die also auch
permanent Lügen, obwohl es irgendwie vollkommen, weil sie nächste Woche ist schon vollkommen klar, nein, sie kriegt jetzt kein Baby, sie hat einfach keins. Irgendwie, warum, warum schreibt er davon, dass da jetzt irgendwie wieder Babyglück ins Haus steht? Weil es
immer nur um diese Illusion geht. Und Leute kaufen es aber auch immer wieder. Und man fragt sich halt, warum
glauben Leute an flache Erde, obwohl es weder belegbar ist und so hochgradig widerlegbar ist, warum glauben sie an diesen Q-Anon? Und es hat einfach viel
damit zu tun, dass das so ein eigener Kult ist. Es geht sozusagen da drum, durch das kritiklose Hinnehmen von Quatsch.
Zu anderen zu zeigen, dass man in diese Gruppe gehört,
Und es ist halt einfach voll mit Leuten, die einfach Schwierigkeiten haben, der anderen Gruppe, der aufgeklärten irgendwie noch zu folgen, weil ihnen diese Welt zu unterkomplex ist oder ich weiß es nicht. Und äh deswegen
kann man da sozusagen auch mit Argumenten und Faktchecking eigentlich relativ wenig erreichen,
gerade umso absurder es wird, umso wichtiger ist es, dass du diesen absurden Thesen auch noch zustimmst und irgendwie Attila Hildmann in den Himmel lobst für sein tolles Engagement, für was auch immer, was es ist, was er vielleicht,
ja? Weil du damit quasi den anderen wahnsinnigen in deiner Gruppe äh äh signalisierst, du bist einfach bereit, jeden Scheiß zu glauben, also gehörst du auch irgendwie dazu,
das macht die Sache auch nochmal doppelt und dreifach äh schwierig.
Ja, es ist wirklich, es scheint ja noch kein Kraut gegen gewachsen zu sein, ne. Das muss man, glaube ich, glaube ich tatsächlich sehr äh.
Das ist ein gesellschaftlicher Lernprozess, den wir da, glaube ich, grade angefangen haben, alle und das wird wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Weile äh halten und ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wann wir hier die ersten Ergebnisse verkünden können, aber,
Sobald es soweit ist, hier erfahrt ihr sofort zuerst.
So, dann äh Urheberrechtsreform haben wir letzte Mal schon ja gesagt, worum da gerade die Detaildiskussion geht, also Patrick darüber gesprochen haben, aber jetzt hat sich noch eine Kleinigkeit getan.
Genau und zwar ist jetzt ein Referentenentwurf der deutschen Bundesregierung bekannt geworden und von Netzpolitik org veröffentlicht worden. Der ist von
einem Monat, zweiter September zwanzig, steht da drauf und das ist jetzt nochmal eine Überarbeitung eines ähm vorher existierenden Entwurfs und.
Und ich muss jetzt sagen
Ich interpretiere jetzt die Interpretation von Julia Reeder in gewisser Hinsicht, ja, äh und auch was Netzpolitik Org dazu geschrieben hat, dass also hier die Regierung wohl dem Druck aus Europa
nachgibt und alles noch ein bisschen schärfer umsetzt als das bislang so kommuniziert wurde. Ich meine mich auch in dieser ganzen Debatte noch zu erinnern, dass die CDU ja irgendwann mal angeblich zurück äh gezogen sei und meint so, ja, nee, Uploadfilter und so weiter, das machen wir dann aber nicht, obwohl wir das jetzt so beschlossen haben, aber das wollen wir ja eigentlich gar nicht. Davon ist jetzt irgendwie nix mehr
zu sehen, sondern so, wie sich das jetzt darstellt, ähm wird hier eine sehr restriktive Auslegung, dieses Leistungsschutzes
Leistungsschutzrechtes ähm angestrebt und so die Interpretation äh
Echtzeit Uploadfilter sind unvermeidbar. Ähm konkreter Streitpunkt an der Stelle ist so Paragraph acht in diesem Entwurf, wo es um,
die sogenannte Kennzeichnung erlaubter Nutzung ging und vorher im alten
Vorschlag, wenn ich's richtig verstanden habe, war das so, dass man eben sagen kann, ja hier, äh das ist jetzt, ich deklariere das mal als einen legalen,
Inhalt und dann muss der gar nicht erst durch diesen Check durch, weil ich gesagt habe, passt schon, schon alles in Ordnung, nicht dass es dann halt noch ähm äh Negativs ähm gibt. Der aktuelle Entwurf.
Scheint wohl eher zu sagen, nö, jetzt muss hier mal einfach mal alles durch den Uploadfilter und du kannst ja danach immer noch behaupten, dass es äh erlaubt sei, aber damit wird dann eben alles automatisch durchgenudelt.
Mann, ey, das ist doch wirklich also und äh den Gesetzentwurf haben wir jetzt äh können wir uns auch nochmal genauer anschauen, ne? Hat äh frag den Staat veröffentlicht.
Von ist ja von Frank äh also auf auf Netzpolitik org liegt ja. Ich.
Bei ist er aber jetzt irgendwie so eingebettet in einen Viewer von frag den Staat und der Artikel ist von Arne Semsrott, insofern.
Habe ich eine Vorstellung, wo die den her haben. Ähm äh also das Ding bleibt nicht äh.
Das Ding bleibt nicht unspannend und man sieht eben auch hier muss ich trotzdem sagen, ne, also das Thema hat damals so viele Menschen.
Beschäftigt und zu so großen Demonstrationen geführt, und man merkt eben, wie man die Leute eben auch so wirklich einfach äh
plattschleifen kann, ne, in diesen politischen Auseinandersetzungen. Da siehst du jetzt keine Bots mehr auf der Straße oder sowas, ne? Die YouTuber äh machen wieder,
Schuhvideos oder sowas, ne? Das heißt, äh da ist dann, da ist jetzt auch das Momentum weg, ähnlich wie bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo auch inzwischen kaum noch einer Durchblick, kaum noch ein Hahn nachkrät. Und eben einige.
Sich über lange Zeiträume hier festbeißen und das Thema hier wie äh insbesondere Patrick Breyer eben über ein Jahrzehnt jetzt begleiten und da immer wieder gegen kämpfen und eben zwischenzeitlich da auch in,
irgendwann mal allein auf weiter Flur stehen, ne? Weil die Karawane weitergezogen ist. Bitter.
Auch bitter sind neue, äh, die gefunden wurden.
Genau, ich bin mir nämlich gar nicht sicher, ob wir das nicht in der letzten Sendung schon kurz erwähnt haben. Also falls ich, ich mache das nur kurz,
gab von Amnesty eine Amnesty International, die haben ja ein digital äh Team, das äh oder Digital Rights Team, das ähm.
Immer äh den Staatstrojanern hinterher äh forscht Claudio Guarnei ist dort.
Glaube so in also einer der Köpfe dieses Teams und die haben relativ viel nochmal von äh entdeckt und zwar
haben sie in Ägypten Einsätze nachgewiesen und haben Mac und Lenux Versionen gefunden von diesem Staatstrojaner, kurze Erinnerung, das ist das Ding aus deutscher,
Gegen das ja die,
für Freiheitsrechte hier auch äh eine Strafanzeige erstattet hat, wegen des Exportes in,
oder das Umgang umgehens von Exportrestriktionen, wir haben damals, Thorsten und ich ein Gutachten.
Äh verfasst, wo wir eben die Belege zusammenfassen, dass es sich hier bei dem Einsatz in der Türkei eben um das Umgehen von Exportrestriktionen handelt. Das war spezifisch dadurch bewiesen worden, dass das Sample eben
nach in Kraft treten der Exportrestriktion äh überhaupt erstellt wurde und wir andererseits durch die Ähnlichkeiten gezeigt haben, dass das,
aus dieser Familie stammt. Hier mit diesem,
entdecken kompletter Mac und Lynux-Varianten ist ein und dem Nachweis des Einsatzes in Ägypten ist ein ungleich größerer Beweis gelungen, ja? Ähm,
der hier die,
Machenschaften dieses Unternehmens ähm aufzeigt und wieder mal zeigt, dass sie eben das mit den Menschenrechten nicht so genau nehmen.
Und es ist langsam auch wirklich nur noch unerträglich, wie man sich seit Jahren, ja, dieses Unternehmen wird ja nicht nur in Deutschland geduldet,
sondern dieses Unternehmen äh wird dem Unternehmen wird nachgesehen, dass es hier offenbar Strukturen zur Umgehung von Exportrestriktionen hat
und nicht nur das, das Unternehmen wird auch selber, Deutschland ist selber Kunde und das schämt
sich noch nicht mal jemand. Das schämt sich noch nicht mal jemand, wenn man sieht, alles klar wird in der Türkei gegen die äh gegen die Opposition eingesetzt, wird in Ägypten, gegen die Opposition eingesetzt, äh um Exportrestriktionen und die deutschen Behörden sagen, Alter, geil, das brauchen wir auch. Das brauchen wir auch, das ist spitze.
Also ähm da weißt du auch irgendwann nicht mehr, was du dazu noch sagen sollst.
Nee, Vanessa ist schon alles zugesagt.
Genau.
Auch alles gesagt, ist eigentlich zu Microsoft Excel, wir hatten das ja hier jetzt schon so ein paar Mal, aber geht immer noch schlimmer.
Ja, wir erinnern uns, äh so gehen
äh Datenbanken in Excelsheets, ganz schlechte Idee, ja? Also Wissenschaftler
natürlich äh so ihre Daten mit ihren Papers veröffentlicht. Das macht man ja Gott sei Dank mittlerweile so, aber dann leider sich eben dafür
entschieden, dass in Excel Dateien zu überführen, wenn sie es nicht gleich schon so veröffentlicht haben. Und dabei liefen natürlich dann so ein paar
Daten zu Grunde, weil Genamen für Excel aussahen wie Datums, Werte und das äh ja, hat's dann einfach so still und heimlich einfach mal in so ein Datum konvertiert, wenn es nicht explizit vorher verhindert wurde.
Und daraufhin wurden die Geno umbenannt.
Und daraufhin wurden die Gene umbenannt, ne.
Unglaublich.
Jetzt schauen wir mal kurz.
Genmanipulation einfach gemacht.
Ja, da, da, da schneidet dann die Genschere quer durch deine Daten, ja? Und ähm.
Excel, super Produkt, hat voll Neumond, das benutzen wir auch, dachte sich, dann äh das
Corona-Track und Trace System des Gesundheitsministeriums in den Vereinigten Königreich. Ja äh
Boris Johnson hat ja vollmundig angekündigt äh schon so vor einem halben Jahr, dass im Anfang Juni sie einen World
System an Start bringen wollten, womit er so weit wie mit das Beste, was irgendwie möglich ist und viel toller als in Deutschland sowieso.
Na ja, Spoiler hat nicht ganz so gut funktioniert. Genau genommen haben sie eigentlich überhaupt nichts am Start. Also wir klagen hier über unsere Kontaktverfolgung, dass es irgendwie kein Vergleich zu dem, wie es da in Großbritannien abgeht,
kam auf jeden Fall eine geile Meldung raus, dass äh Daten verloren gegangen sind, unter anderem, weil ähm,
Excel zum Einsatz kam, was nämlich hier passiert ist, ist dass die Labore, die positiven Tests, die sie gefunden hatten, als CSV Datei
an diese Gruppe namens Public Health England weitergeleitet hat. Das ist quasi so der Teil des Gesundheitsministeriums, der sich eben um diese Krisensituation kümmern soll, nicht nur um Corona, aber eben vor allem auch und wo dann eben diese ganzen offiziellen
Zahlen, dann tabuliert werden aufgrund dann eben derer äh andere Entscheidungen gefällt werden, also entsprechende Warnungen ausgeschickt werden oder die Maßnahmen verschärft werden,
Problem war, dass sie
quasi diese CSV Dateien immer genommen haben und dann hinten ans Ende ihrer Excel-Datei automatisch gependelt haben und dann äh mittlerweile, weil sie so viele Fälle haben, an ein interessantes Limit gestoßen sind
nämlich ein Limit von ein einer Millionen achtundvierzigtausendfünfhundertsechsundsiebzig Zeilen. Und wer sich.
Zwei hoch zwanzig.
Zwei hoch zwanzig, genau, wer äh das System verinnerlicht hat, weiß sofort Bescheid. Da ist nämlich dann halt einfach die Grenze. Also wer sich schon immer mal gewundert hat, wie lange man in diese äh Stretchheats einfach so nach unten aufziehen kann, da ist Schluss.
Früher gab's äh noch ein anderes äh Limites bei zwei Hoch sechzehn lag. Da konnte man also nicht mehr als fünfundsechzigtausendfünfhundertsechsunddreißig Zahlen machen
und äh dann haben sie sich gedacht, naja, aber Millionen reicht ja, wer hat denn schon mehr als eine Million? Die Leute würden ja nicht anfangen und es bretscht als Datenbank benutzen. Was?
Also warte mal, mit anderen Worten, die hatten schon mal das Limit. Also die haben irgendwann festgestellt, okay, wir reservieren mal zwei Bite für die Zeilenlänge und als das zu wenig war, haben sie gesagt, naja, okay, gehen wir mal noch ein halbes dazu.
Und da merkst du auch schon, dass das halt irgend so ein abritäres Limit ist. Ja, also da ist irgendwo wirklich ein, wenn hier Überlauf von zwanzig Bit, dann nö. So,
und das ist auch nicht so, dass sie dann einfach einen Fehler anzeigen wollen und sagen, oh wie konntest.
Schneiden das einfach ab, weil weil sonst hätten die in ihrem Code Jungle nämlich äh im Zweifelsfall irgendwo zweiundfünfzigtausend äh äh Waffen.
Es darf nicht sein, äh was nicht äh es es kann nicht sein, was nicht sein darf und deswegen wird das halt einfach ähm ja kommentarlos einfach weggelassen. Das hatte dann zu.
Dass dann fünfzehntausendachthunderteinundvierzig positive Covid
verloren gegangen sind über einen Zeitraum von irgendwie fünfundzwanzigsten September bis zweiten Oktober äh war's dann sozusagen wiederum dazu geführt hat, dass sie einen massiven Anstieg der Infektionszahlen schlicht,
bemerkt haben. Das heißt, ihr könnt keine entsprechenden Maßnahmen einleiten. Ja, ja, ja, also.
Und wie haben sie's gelöst? Wie haben sie's gelöst?
Jetzt haben sie das halt so nachge äh meldet und äh wie sie's jetzt technisch genau machen, äh kann ich dir nicht sagen. Ach nee, also es ging ein Gerücht rum, dass sie das jetzt in so Badges aufteilen. Das heißt, sie.
Naheliegende Lösung. Sie waren einfach zwei Excel-Dateien.
Geht auch. Das wird.
Ich frage mich auch ernsthaft, also ich muss ja auch manchmal Excel benutzen. Und also manchmal habe ich auch wirklich, sage ich mal, einen größeren, größeren Datenstand da drin, ne? Und ich muss echt sagen, ne.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele CPU-Kerne und wie viel Ram du brauchst, um überhaupt einen Excel-Dokument mit mehr als, sagen wir mal.
Dreihunderttausend Zeilen.
Bearbeiten zu können, also an dieses an die Leute, die irgendwie ein Exitsheat mit einer Million Zeilen öffnen
und dann nach unten scrollen oder was auch immer, ja? Also das ist wirklich sehr ungeeignet. Das ist ungefähr so wie also das,
Wahnsinn.
Die scrollen nicht, die haben da einfach ihre Makros und äh dann dann läuft das entsprechend. Naja, so.
Also es gab auf jeden Fall, würde ich dazu noch sagen, es gibt da dazu zwei Tweets, die ich sehr schön fand. Ähm und zwar erstmal die Frage von Huns. Äh gibt es eigentlich ein Exitheet, in dem festgehalten wird, wie viele Leute schon durch Probleme mit Excelsheets gestorben sind?
Antwort, Antwort kommt von Bernd Bandeko. Ich habe dazu mal ein Exitheater gemacht. Es sind fünfte April neunzehnhundertsechsundachtzig.
Sehr schön.
Äh
Ähm wobei man jetzt also wirklich, also klar, es ist eine Katastrophe von Excel, aber es ist auch wirklich eine Katastrophe, dass jemand zwanzig zwanzig meint, so etwas ginge mit Excel, ne. Also da es wurden schon mal Datenbanken erfunden.
Und und in mir ist auch nicht ganz klar, warum die in diesem einfach alle Fälle immer haben mussten. Vielleicht weil sie eine Statistik rechnen mussten, aber hier ging's ja offenbar auch um den ähm,
Um den äh um die Alarmierung, ne? Oder ist es genau, weil das äh um das ja, also da verstehe ich auch nicht, dass dir nicht auffällt. So Mensch, super Pandemie vorbei, ne. Die haben ja offenbar vom fünfundzwanzigsten September bis zweiten Oktober gesagt, so, ach super, äh,
ruhige, ruhige Woche. Können wir endlich mal unseren Backlog arbeiten.
Abarbeiten oder so. Also ich ich weiß auch nicht genau, was da los ist. Naja, so. Kurze Sendung.
Ähm wir sind schon am Ende, ne? Spitze, finde ich gut.
Finde ich auch gut. Danke sagen.
Ich danke ähm herzlich, Marek, vielen Dank, Matthias, herzlichen Dank und dem Ben zum wiederholten Male, Wiederholungstäter, Serientäter, möchte ich sagen, vielen herzlichen Dank.
Ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank an alle Unterstützer von Lokbuch, Netzpolitik, ähm ihr wisst, wer ihr seid und wir hören uns irgendwie nächste Woche wieder.
Tragt eure blöden Masken und äh versucht euch mal ein bisschen.
Verantwortungsvoller zu verhalten, insbesondere wenn ihr im Gastgewerbe seid und.
Dann äh kann ich ansonsten nur in Anbetracht
der nun dann doch wieder sehr starken Einschränkungen des äh Freizeitvergnügens sowohl im abendlichen Geschehen in Berlin ja, Sperrstunde dreiundzwanzig Uhr als auch tagsüber mit der,
fortschreitenden ähm Verringer Verdunkelung
fortschreitende Verdunkelungsgefahr, die mit dieser Jahreszeit einhergeht, äh nochmal dazu raten, euch den äh Podcast vom
Anfang von vor dem Lockdown anzuhören, indem ich ein paar Tipps gegeben habe, wie man durch diese Krise kommen kann. Im Winter würde ich das dann noch durch
Vitamin D3 und Johanniskraut übrigens ersetzen. Ja?
Könnte ich eigentlich mein Amazon-Link machen? Mache ich jetzt mal? Ja, mache ich. Ich mache jetzt so ein Amazon-Affiliate-Link. Dann gibt's wieder Kommentare, die sich darüber beschweren, dass wir dir Datenkrake äh zuträglich sind.
Und natürlich total kommerziell auch.
Und Berliner äh bitte hier kein Risikogebiet rausmacht. Ich muss jetzt demnächst viel reisen.
Ja, ne, dann muss ich, muss ich mitm Wohnwagen äh demnächst irgendwie verreisen, um mir meine Interviews zu machen. Es ist schon kommen. Ich sehe es schon kommen.
Weil ach so wegen des Beherbergungs verputzt. Besser.
Ja genau. Gut, das war schon immer der Plan, aber ich dacht.
Beherbergt hier keiner. Ich ja, wir werden äh uns wird auch das Lachen in der in der Pandemie nicht ausgehen.
Nicht ausgehen. Wo kommen wir denn, wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Alles klar, tschau, tschau.